de préparation pour voir ce projet se
réaliser
[Musique]
l'astronaute Steve Bowen répond en
anglais et les élèves sont impressionnés
par les moments qui viennent de vivre
c'était super vraiment c'était très
stressant au débarque mais une fois
qu'on est passé c'est génial d'avoir pu
l'entendre ça c'est vraiment on se dit
comment c'est possible de parler avec
quelqu'un qui est dans l'ISS c'est
vraiment génial c'est inoubliable ça va
rester dans nos mémoires même on pourra
peut-être le raconter à nos envois quand
on sera plus grand c'est leur professeur
de technologie qui est à l'initiative de
ce projet hors du commun grâce au fait
que je sois radioamateur donc j'ai pu
discuter de ce projet à Ris avec le
radio club F6 KSD de Besançon et ils ont
tout de suite accroché sur ce sur ce
projet et à partir de là ce sont
enchaînés donc des activités des
interventions des radios amateurs sur
plus d'une année jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui à ce contact qui était
fabuleux l'échange c'est évidemment la
fierté du directeur du collège Saint en
étoile
alors fier oui fier pour les élèves
parce que c'est un moment qui oublieront
pas je pense que toutes les personnes
ici présentes se souviendront de cet
instant
fière aussi parce que Monsieur Girardin
a fait un super projet vraiment à il y a
quelques membres de l'équipe qui l'ont
dit mais c'est vraiment lui qui a tout
porté avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme tout
au long de 6 mois parce que c'était des
mois et des mois d'attente un des étapes
après étape il nous est bah là on est
retenu
petit à petit on s'est pris à rêver et
le rêve est le rêve on a vécu ce rêve
voilà
un cours en visioconférence qu'élève
comme professeur ne sont pas prêts
d'oublier